ouais ça fumait a manqué depuis dix ans
world disant ouais quoi ça faisait dix
ans que cette infime télé c'est une
dinguerie ouais non je te crois pas je
te jure si ou frères effet dix ans et
qui s'est passé tu avais pas envie tu
avais plus envie d'en haut c'est pas ça
pas du tout le moment j'avais besoin de
me ressourcer j'ai fait un voyage
culturel
je suis parti travailler je suis parti
créé avec des gens formidables et partez
au marrakech
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ensuite c'est
vrai que voilà ta tête c'est toi qui a
voulu arrêter la chanson dont on n'a pas
arrêté du tout pas du tout non
je me suis je me suis mis à bosser créé
à faire des concerts dans le monde
entier ce qui a pas que la france
d'accord et parce que c'est une musique
l'avoir musique qu'on exporte dans le
monde entier et voilà mais c'est vrai
que ça m'avait acheté gt gt gt pas très
bien à un moment donné je pense que
c'était un cumul de beaucoup de choses
mais c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens
sont restés figés sur la sarkozie en
fait vous voyez comme que comme le
soutient nicolas cervenak soyez brut
comme le petit prince du raï avec
compléter et nicolas sarkozy donc après
une fois qu'ils étaient lus tout à utah
idées nous souhaiterions ensuite vous
non plus un coup de fil ah ouais du tout
ou alors il était bien il était
président en septembre il faut lui poser
la question mais je veux dire fou dont
on a bien rigolé on a fait mon faye et
c'est maintenant un j'ai du travail je
suis président d'un bce et donc état et
celles aux joints vous et non pas du
tout non mais puisque je suis pas comme
ça non non c'est vrai t'as envie de
revoir ou pas la vérité non non ça va
quand même il est pas là mais il était
pressenti pour être ministre non plus
donc du boulot
voilà c'est vrai qu'après côté président
c'est pas pareil aussi mais avec quoi
enrico macias pareil qui s'était
affichée ouais et on lui en a voulu
aussi oui oui oui les temps la carte ici
après mois par rapport à ça j'ai envie
de dire c'est un choix personnel après
les gens aient choisi ce qu'ils veulent
ils soutiennent qu'ils veulent à moi
tu peux pas interdire à des gens de
choisir telle personne tout ce qu'elle
est de gauche parce qu'elle est de
droite ou parce qu'elle est du milieu ou
fin c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de viviez
quelqu'un après c'est la question la
question qu'on peut se poser la jet c
est ce qu il faut
quand on a personnage public s'afficher
aux côtés d'un d'un nom est un
personnage politique c'est vrai que ça
n'a jamais porté chance
maintenant ce que je dis non à l'accord
tui derrière away
mais je pense que j'ai dû donner
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens par rapport
à moi ne sont sont complètement presse à
kiev c'est quoi maintenant il ya la
jurisprudence faudel najet oui je
voulais quelque chose par rapport à ce
que tu disais vous êtes vous dit en gros
comment faut pas s'afficher tout ça et
nous en france on dit soi disant faut en
a le droit d'expression à la liberté
tout ça en vrai c'est pas parce que tu
dis ce que tu parles c'est que tu fais
des choix se déjuger quoi qu'il arrive
j'entends beaucoup de noms mais je dire
beaucoup d'artistes un faux cul aussi la
vérité sont tous de droite et qui te
disent la gauche la gauche mais hors
antenne la vérité on ne citera personnes
devraient dire un truc c'est que moi
j'étais j'ai été très longtemps parce
que moi j'étais en fait le gars le plus
en galère du showbiz cependant bien 15 à
15 da 40 chacun c'est à dire ouais un
essai avec comme modèle
il m'a invité à déjeuner 12h je me
donnais pas des niches pour rappel il
avait un gars elle travaille ou pas
aujourd'hui dix fois plus blog est moche
gfr il faut j'ai rien j'ai rien sur moi
t'aimer fois certains mais c'est vrai
j'étais en grosse galère d'oseille et
faudel il m'a vite et très souvent à des
jeunes et que son cousin jean rachid j
ai revu ses chiffres et donc je voudrais
être remercié parce que voilà tu m'a
beaucoup aidé merci
et tu sais et méfie toi tout ce que
disent les gens que c'est les chiffres
qui sont annoncés ne sont pas les bons
on doit même aux couvertures de
magazines people magazine qui te prête
une relation avec séverine ferrer fans
de m6 et ewen et je te jure que c'est
une fille magnifique moi j'adore c'est
vrai il y avait un noyau à dos à dire il
ya eu on était à nant ensemble à la
galoche et tout
[Musique]
on peut demander frère a tant d'amour
alors bac à linge d'amour mais alors
mais attend des cantons qui fut men
origins
elle aime bien me battre et aller
directement qu'il est petit pour le
galop c'est non mais c'est vrai quoi toi
que tu vas revenir sur bad ragaz céline
un gros problème aujourd'hui est donc
elle a parlé de cette relation il ya
quelques temps
regarde ce qu'elle a dit séverine ferrer
a toujours très mignonne ouais du pays
salah est ce que cette histoire avec
faudel était une paparazzade ou une
véritable histoire d'amour
ça a été un coup de coeur je peux pas
dire ce fut une vraie histoire d'amour
ça a été un réel coup de coeur de
tendresse j'ai beaucoup de tendresse
pour lui on s'est revus à quelques temps
et c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'affection on est
passés l'un à côté de l'autre ça c'est
une certitude
on était quand on était jeunes donc re
l'âme et on ne regrette rien et moi je
suis très contente d'avoir vécu ce que
j'ai a duré combien de temps ça dure et
c'est pas trois quatre mois
[Applaudissements]
ya un problème
apparemment squattée resta non
avec la mère d'un coup de fil mais elle
était en délire us d'actifs